Oh
thank God you know I've tried everything
I've tried self-help and I'm tryna the
secret 12 steps this dick-sucker whore
has cracked the code can I interest you
in this is not happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. Roy I did it
again hello Roy
pass the water on does it feel
[Music]
[Applause]
New York City Crime Report
[Music]
I'm not local I live in New York with it
I live in Chelsea and before that it was
Queens and before that I lived in my car
but not poverty or anything I just I had
this idea that I wanted to be in show
business
I would be on the road to it stand up
35 or 40 or 45 weeks a year and it's I
know it sounds glamorous but you know
the truth is it's not it beats working
though working is the worst and so one
week I was not working in Nashville and
I met this girl working in the box
office and she told me she was having a
birthday party that night and it was the
Wednesday the first night of the week so
I went and when I got there I saw orange
she was dancing this natural redhead and
she was wearing skin-tight leopard print
pants and she was laughing the whole
time she danced never seen anybody like
that and we were introduced and she just
had this intensity you know she's like
hyper sexual and just really interesting
right off and I kind of halfway fell in
love with her really right then you know
and she gave me a big hug
before she left me standing there and
she was covered with this light it was
like a mist around her you know she's
been dancing in warm his room and or the
room was warm the warm was not room at
all but
she's been dancing and she was kind of a
sweaty you know and and I got close to
her soul she gave me one of those hugs
like he gave somebody that he used to
but he's since moved on and
somewhere between like her hair and
shoulder right there and I kind of whiff
of like sex
you know just the smell you know and I
was the first time I smelled Laura and
Laura she expressed a little attraction
towards me I think I don't know
sometimes these things to be
misinterpreted but I I took it that way
you know because she said to me if you
weren't married I would take you home
and your off and although it
was true I was married I took that as a
firm offer so and my marriage was kind
of lousy and we didn't talk to each
other anymore we didn't live or I was on
the road I've gone a lot it was a home
and we started to have less and less in
common Laura on the other hand pretty
flexible and she was similar to me and
she was like no responsibilities and she
would sleep on couches and she just kind
of was willing to travel and so it got
to be a habit whenever I would leave
town I would pick her up and we would go
and have sex in hotels cheap ones mostly
disgusting I know it's disgusting it
really is but I loved her I was just
madly in love with her I mean she's a
beautiful girl red hair and blue eyes
and her answer to everything was yes
and I don't have any defense for that
right then yeah I mean if you meet
somebody and they fill a void in you you
know and you seem to fill a void in them
and you guys are filling each other's
voice and you should just there's one
thing you should do run away you know
like a woman will blow you a couple of
times a day if you want you have that
going and it changes your life it
changes the way you process things you
start thinking everything's great thank
you your life is falling apart you know
but it but it feels like everything's
finally coming together
man never right you're skipping you've
got a spring in your skip you know thank
God you know I've tried everything I've
tried self-help and I've tried the
secret and twelve steps with it
this dick-sucking whore has cracked the
code there's more and more time I was
hurting to see her pissed you know and
and as we moved into the summer through
the summer I got to be July and we had a
big falling out and she left in her
rental car I figured that's it no that's
yeah ran its course and when the phone
rang a couple days later it was her and
I figured it was foreclosure but it
wasn't she told me all about how she had
downed a lot of liquor and pills and had
to be revived in a hospital outside of
Atlanta and she had been dead and
brought back to life you know a lot of
guys will bail after the first suicide
attempt but I had a lot of hope
and and in fact I think it made the
relationship stronger and you know I
don't know if you've had this experience
maybe you have but you meet a girl and
it's great it's nice and then you start
to notice some inconsistencies here and
there
things don't quite add up and then she
starts talking about killing herself
anybody I mean it doesn't have to be a
woman and a guy you know yeah but the
and and all the suicide talk you know
she's I kind of she used to say over one
time she told me when you get back from
the from the show I'm gonna be dead be
dead in your hotel room when someone
says that you say oh my god don't do
that Jesus it's terrible whatever you do
don't do that you know at first and then
eventually she tells it would it be dead
in your hotel room when you get back and
you go it sounds like a housekeeping
issue
[Laughter]
I'll mention it and it would solve a lot
of problems for me actually if you would
go ahead and pull the trigger on that
plan cuz I mean you know how it goes I
mean you know they hit the attempted
suicide and then the talk about suicide
or like I can't give this bitch a reason
to live you know and then when you
finally want to break up with her what
happens then
she wants to tell your wife everything I
know we've all been there so my wife
left and that was for good it was more
of a formality than anything and then
we're together all the time
Laura and I you know she she like I said
kept everything in a couple of duffel
bags and so she threw those in the trunk
of my car and from that point on it was
kind of a blur
sex and and hotels and fighting a lot of
fighting you know a lot of suicide talk
you can't stop the suicide talk only one
way to do that that didn't occur and you
know and there was a fake pregnancy then
you know she told me she was pregnant
and fortunately was followed by a fake
miscarriage and I mean you you have to
kind of take her at her word at some
point oh you're pregnant how do I prove
she's not and so that becomes your truth
you know and now you're living in this
insanity you know but I came a lot and
and so that's what keeps you in you know
what I mean is that this the sex is so
good you know I'm saying that it's like
the closest thing to like evidence of
the existence of God that you've ever
seen you know and deep down we all want
to believe and she's always threatening
the cops even with the suicide talk it's
a I don't know how to handle this so
that I think I should call the police
because I think we need help but you go
if you call the police I'll tell them
you were hitting me and you'll go to
jail well well played
I was very little equipped to deal with
this situation I remember one time was
in Indiana she told me you know we were
fighting and everything and I was trying
to get rid of her like we have to break
up this is insanity I hate this you know
we felt imprisoned you know she goes I
don't really I'll go you one better if
you give me $200 you'll never see me
again yes I had $200 in my hand by the
time she finished his sentence just took
the money she looked at it folded it
tucked it into her bra sat down on the
couch and read a magazine and you win
you know we never spoke of it again yes
yet again you win
so she was drunk one night and I took
her home I left her with her mother and
and and that was it I felt so free and
alive and I felt so good just to be
alone again you know and did not have
all her in my trunk and then the
phone started ringing and it rang
throughout December it would ring 36
times day 25 times a day and I'm a brat
we had a mutual friend who was gonna
come and we were gonna work together in
Chattanooga Tennessee and that's close
to Nashville so I said don't call her
don't tell her you're gonna be around
okay because she's kind of stalking me
he's like oh yeah yeah I've had him do
that before tonight it's serious okay
you know tried to emphasize it
she called me 15 minutes later and said
hey quit telling people I'm stalking you
okay said you don't know the meaning of
stalk and there was a January 4th 2004
and I remember the date because that's a
date that someone tried to murder me I
went to the IHOP International House of
Pancakes I've had many great experiences
there and like the food good service you
know so I get out of the car and I'm
walking into the restaurant and I hear
my name is Dixon you know I turn around
and there she is you know so angry grabs
me by the arm you know she says just
want to talk I just want to talk to you
I just want to talk to you II don't like
Christ so I'm trying to work my way
towards the pancakes we get right up to
the door and she reaches into her jeans
pocket and she pulls out this
9-millimeter Glock that's why I later
found out that's what it was at the time
my brain just processes go yeah but uh
she goes look I've got this 9-millimeter
and I grabbed her wrist and I just shake
the gun out of her hand you know squeeze
it out she jumped on my back and she
starts scratching my face you know she's
growling like something like an animal
you know and she's injured or something
she's holding onto my head by my eyes
you know she's digging into my eyes
trying to trying to squeeze my eyeballs
and everything and so I had the gun in
my hand and I got inside and I slid it
across the floor and there was a
security guards there did I hop pretty
good luck and they separate us and you
know I was outside she was inside and
then I heard those banging on the window
you know I turn around and it was her
you know she's like and she was as if
she'd gotten what she wanted you know
mission accomplished
take that so it's filling out a police
report a few minutes later and a
policeman came over and there's a funny
thing he's he says you know and I found
out from him that that they had told
Hurley what they said well what did you
intend to do with the gun and she said I
was gonna shoot that and
then shoot myself I said ah she said
like that all the time
[Applause]